what we're going to do in this video is
talk about type
1 errors
and
type 2
type
2 errors
and this is in the context of
significance testing so just as a little
bit of review in order to do a
significance test we first come up with
a null
and an alternative hypothesis and we'll
do this on some population in question
these will say some hypotheses about a
true parameter for this population and
the null hypothesis tends to be kind of
what was always assumed or the status
quo while the alternative hypothesis hey
there's news here there's there's
there's something alternative here
and to test it and we're really testing
the null hypothesis we're going to
decide whether we want to reject or fail
to reject the null hypothesis we take a
sample we take a sample from this
population
using that sample we calculate a
statistic
we calculate a statistic that's trying
to estimate the parameter in question
and then using that statistic we try to
come up with the probability of getting
that statistic
the probability of getting that
statistic that we just calculated from
that sample of a certain size
given if we were to assume
that our null hypothesis
if our null hypothesis is true
and if this probability which is often
known as a p-value is below some
threshold that we set ahead of time
which is known as the significance level
then we reject the null hypothesis let
me write this down so this right over
here this is our p
value this should be i'll be review we
introduce it in other videos we have
seen in other videos if our p-value
is less than our significance level
then we
reject reject our null hypothesis and if
our p value
is greater than or equal to our
significance level alpha then we fail to
reject
fail
to
reject
our null hypothesis and when we reject
our null hypothesis some people will say
that might suggest the alternative
hypothesis and the reason why this makes
sense is if the probability of getting
this statistic from a sample of a
certain size if we assume that the null
hypothesis is true is reasonably low if
it's below a threshold maybe the
threshold is five percent if the
probability of that happening was less
than five percent then hey maybe it's
reasonable to reject it
but we might be wrong in either of these
scenarios and that's where these errors
come into play
let's make a grid to make this clear
so there's the reality let me put
reality up here so the reality is
there's two possible scenarios in
reality one is is that the null
hypothesis is true and the other is that
the null hypothesis
is false
and then based on our significance test
there's two things that we might do
we might reject
the null hypothesis or we might fail
to
reject
the null hypothesis
and so let's put a little grid here
to think about the different
combinations the different scenarios
here
so in a scenario where the null
hypothesis is true
but we rejected that feels like an error
we shouldn't reject something that is
true and that indeed is a type one error
type
one
error
you shouldn't reject the null hypothesis
if it was true and you can even figure
out what is the probability of getting a
type one error well that's going to be
your significance level because if your
null hypothesis is true let's say that
their your significance level is five
percent well five percent of the time
even if your null hypothesis is true
you're going to get a statistic that's
going to make you reject the null
hypothesis so one way to think about the
probability of a type 1 error is your
significance level
now if your null hypothesis is true and
you fail to reject it well that's good
this we could write this as this is a
correct
correct conclusion
the good thing just happened to happen
this time
now if your null hypothesis is false and
you reject it that's also good that is
the correct
correct
conclusion
but if your null hypothesis is false
and you fail to reject it well then that
is a type 2 error
that is a type 2 error
now with this context in the next few
videos we will actually do some examples
where we try to identify one whether an
error is occurring and whether that
error is a type 1 or a type 2.